les médecins ses héros ses deux milieux
qui ont le pouvoir de guérir et même le
pouvoir de vie et de mort sur leurs
congénères
mais s'il ya un grand pouvoir implique
de grandes responsabilités
il peut aussi faire perdre le sens des
réalités voici cinq types de médecins et
qui vous n'avez pas du tout envie de
confier votre petit corps gracieux et
vous allez bien raison
première catégorie le médecin trop
conciliant ah oui ça peut paraître
bizarre mais des fois c'est bien quand
un médecin refuse de faire ce que vous
lui demandez quand vous demandez quelque
chose de pas raisonnables par exemple
tenait le premier le docteur conrad
murray
l'homme qui a tué michael jackson bat
s'il avait su dire non à son client
quand en plus du cocktail de médicaments
qui prenait déjà il lui a demandé un
anesthésiant en guise de somnifères
ben michael serait encore en vie enfin
il serait pas mort si tôt en tout cas il
ne serait pas mort de sa part bref
imaginez c'est un peu comme si vous
demandez à votre médecin de vous
prescrire une chimio pour plus avoir
besoin de vous épiler
ça peut marcher mais c'est pas bon pour
vous dans sa défense conrad murray a dit
je cite nous étions une famille on sait
mais comme des frères vous voulez savoir
à quel point on était proche
je tenais son pénis dans mes mains
chaque nuit une façon un peu ma les
antes de dire qu'il mettait une sonde
urinaire tous les soirs au chanteur
parce qu'ils aient pipi au lit
normalement dans ces cas-là une couche
ça suffit quand je vous dis qu'il est
vraiment trop conciliant autres types de
médecins à fuir comme la peste
après celui était trop conciliant celui
qui se croit tout de suite sans oublier
que vous êtes là et que vous avez votre
mot à dire comme graeme stephen wood en
2002 ce médecin australien opérait une
de ses patientes d'une tumeur au niveau
de la vulve les lèvres pour être précis
et au lieu d'enlever uniquement la
tumeur mais il a tout retiré y compris
clitoris une infirmière qui a témoigné à
son procès a raconté que quand elle lui
a fait remarquer que la patiente était
pas au courant qu'ils allaient tous
retirés et qu'elle n'avait pas donné son
consentement
il a dit que de toute façon étant donné
qu'elle était veuve elle aurait plus
besoin de tout ça ensuite il a retiré
ses gants de chirurgien il est monté sur
son cheval et il est rentré chez lui au
moyen-âge manon en vraie graine brésil a
fini en prison parce qu'il s'est avéré
que des centaines de plaintes ont été
déposées contre lui pour mutilation et
agression sexuelle le boucher de bay
gars comme on l'a appelé il a bien été
radié de l'ordre des médecins
mais par contre il est sorti de prison
toujours dans la catégorie débouché deux
médecins qui ont exercé en france
un dentiste et un chirurgien esthétique
le premier s'appelle marc venir up mais
vous ne connaissez peut-être sous le nom
du dentiste de l'horreur il a été jugé
en février 2016 pour avoir mutilé des
dizaines de patients dans scène
dévitalisées arrachage par paquets duit
gencives coupé douleur j'en passe et des
meilleurs le tout pour l'appât de
l'argent et sans jamais montré la
moindre compassion
pas même à son procès le second c'est le
docteur maure alors je sais pas vous
mais moi un médecin avec un nom pareil
d'emblée je suis pas serein il s'avère
que le bonhomme pratiquer la chirurgie
esthétique comme d'autres le fist
fucking à la hussarde et sans anesthésie
sauf que là en l'occurrence les patients
n'étaient pas du tout qu'on s'entend
certains ont raconté que pendant les
interventions il sentait les mains du
chirurgien sous leur peau pour un
résultat en plus assez approximatif
hashtag euphémisme avant la fin de son
procès le dr moore s'est enfui sur son
yacht est normal mais bon elle a fini
par être rattrapé et il a été condamné à
quatre ans de prison dont un avec sursis
autre catégorie de médecins à éviter à
tout prix
l'apprenti sorcier celui qui tente des
trucs qui sont pas dans le manuel comme
o'neal ron maurice une jeune
chirurgienne esthétique amateurs qui
officié en floride sans diplôme et avec
des méthodes très personnel pour ses
opérations de remodelage des joues des
lèvres des fesses et du menton l
injecter à ses patientes un mélange de
colle de mousses anti-crevaison d'huile
et de ciment le tout dans des chambres
d'hôtel ou directement au domicile de
ses patientes
après plusieurs cas d'infections graves
et même après un décès elle a eu
l'occasion d'aller méditer au calme en
prison sur la notion d'exercice illégal
de la médecine et d'hygiène aussi comme
la majorité de ses congénères o'neal
rhône maurice a gagné dans l'histoire un
joli petit surnom toxiques tech doctor
doctor est toxique
normalement être créatifs pour un
décorateur d'intérieur c'est cool pour
un coiffeur à la limite et pour un
chirurgien était plutôt conventionnel
dernière catégorie celle des médecins
qui se donne un peu trop corps et âme à
leur métier
premier exemple cécile jacobsson un
médecin du colorado spécialisé dans les
ans amy nation artificiel vous le sentez
venir
et oui le bonhomme avait la sinistre
habitude de remplir lui même les stocks
de sa banque de sperme il féconde et ses
patientes avec ses propres échantillons
et il allait même parfois jusqu'à
remplacer ceux de leur mari il aurait
ainsi donné naissance à 70 voire 80
enfants ce qui lui a valu un surnom
d'inséminateur de d'inspirer un film est
roi un petit séjour en prison
autre spécimen le britannique berthold
wiessner que j'ai personnellement
surnommé un séminaire corps il a exercée
jusqu'au milieu des années 60 dans les
mêmes conditions que son confrère ccid
jacobson il pourrait être le géniteur de
300 à 600 enfants voire un millier selon
certaines estimations
et il a fallu faire des estimations pas
ce qu'est le pot-aux-roses a été
découvert qu'après sa mort
voilà la prochaine fois que vous irez
chez votre médecin m'a fait lui un petit
bisou ok il est revenu parce qu'il est
toujours en retard et qu'il écrit comme
un [ __ ] et vous auriez pu plus mal
tomber dans ce top est terminée si vous
avez des questions à me poser sur la
santé ou le corps humain les faits moi
ça dans les commentaires
on se retrouve très vite pour parler de
choses qui nous concerne toutes et tous
où ça monte encore à beaune thouars